now tonight a hannity investigation more
developments have come to light
surrounding mr zero experience hunter
biden as multiple highly credible
whistleblowers democrats love
whistleblowers right they have now come
forward to iowa senator chuck grassley
detailing what they say is an effort
from inside the fbi to discredit
information about hunter biden and his
nefarious foreign dealings according to
grassley's letter to the fbi quote the
allegations provided to my office appear
to indicate that there was a scheme in
place among certain fbi officials to
undermine derogatory information
connected to hunter biden by falsely
suggesting it was disinformation now it
was just the latest evidence of a
two-tier justice system inside the fbi
and this politicized department of
justice and how these institutions are
both politicized and that's not all
according to a new report from the
washington examiner delaware police
considered hunter biden the victim back
in 2018 when his handgun was tossed near
a grocery store by his sister-in-law
hallie biden no charges ever filed in
the incident no charges connected to him
lying on his gun application and tonight
wisconsin senator ron johnson has also
sent a letter to the fbi director
christopher wray pressing the bureau for
more transparency and laying out more
evidence to
their efforts to undermine the
investigation into hunter biden and the
biden family syndicate here with
reaction uh reaction uh wisconsin
senator ron johnson by the way i have
noticed and many are taking note tens of
millions of dollars from outside of
wisconsin is flowing into your state to
try to take you out you've become the
number one target uh for democrats uh in
this election cycle uh i don't know if
that's an honor or a distinction but
it's happening is that true
it's over 44 million dollars so far so
ron johnson for senate dot com i'm
getting a lot of help if you want me to
continue my investigations
yeah i'm sure that everybody in
wisconsin loves people outside of
wisconsin telling them who to vote for
all right this is important because
if you go back to 2016
there was a big lie perpetrated hillary
clinton's bought and paid for dirty
russian dossier then becomes the basis
of a fisa application it's unverifiable
it's been debunked four separate
warrants never verified or verifiable
then in the lead up to the 2020 election
weeks before we get this laptop from
hell now it's been verified and yet
still the fbi and people in the media
and the democratic party and all these
intel officials past and present oh no
no this looks like russian
disinformation so they use russia in two
elections in two different ways to
impact our elections how many how many
more times are the democrats going to
play that game and get away with it
oh it's their playbook let me first
thank the whistleblowers
for coming forward we need a lot more
whistleblowers inside the fbi department
of justice the federal health agencies
if we're going to restore credibility to
these agencies we need to know the truth
and that's going to require
whistleblowers but you know
unfortunately sean i don't find this
revelation shocking it's outrageous
but you know there's so many things that
were suspicious you know for example
senator grassley and i both received
briefings we didn't request
from the fbi they were later leaked to
the washington post
to smear us and discredit our our
investigation i'll never forget peter
strzok's uh text to lisa page said that
our sisters are are leaking like mad
feeling scorned worried and political
they're kicking into overdrive and now
now we're finding out for these
whistleblowers that the fbi actually had
you know
i don't know what you would call it but
individuals uh specifically taking
derogatory information about against
hunter biden downgrading it to end the
investigations
were they were they responsible talking
to their intelligence sisters of the 51
intelligence officials that came forward
and engaged in their own information
operation when they said that
hunter biden's laptop
had all the earmarks of a russian
information operation
this is dirty this is corrupt we need
answers and christopher wray
attorney general merrick garland these
people have to come clean and tell us
what we know
we this may need we may need a special
counsel on this one well i i would agree
with you but why would we have any
confidence in them because
you mentioned well we could talk about
comey mccabe struck page and a whole
list of other people nobody's ever held
accountable
and then time passes and they move on
christopher wray hasn't cleaned up the
fbi he hasn't done he hasn't lifted a
finger to
to take on the abuse of power that took
place with the russian lie or the lies
to the fisa court on four separate
occasions
he hasn't taken on any of the people
that said hunter biden's laptop was
disinformation he hasn't done anything
to clean
everything up and as far as the
department of justice okay
what happened on january 6 was wrong i
said it in real time i said it that
night on this show
i'll say it again tonight but so were
the 574 riots in the summer of 2020 that
if i'm not mistaken kamala harris
defended and said beware take note they
won't stop they shouldn't stop we're not
going to stop
and then promoted a bail fund for the
rioters how come that's not important
how come the people on videotape rioting
and burning down you know businesses and
police precincts how come those people
haven't been held accountable
because we have highly partisan
political actors inside these federal
agencies and that's why we need to get
to the bottom of this this is why we
need more whistleblowers coming forward
patriots that
actually
appreciate their agencies want to see
credibility integrity restored to them
the only way we're going to restore that
credibility because i don't trust
christopher wray remember under his his
leadership the fbi briefed the senate
intel committee in march of 2018 that
the steele dossier had integrity even
though the fbi knew it was russian
disinformation he's the one that was
there while this operation was
apparently set up he's the one that
potentially directed the briefing to
senator grassley and i that were that
was then leaked and then used to smear
us so no i don't trust him but he's the
one we've got to call on to answer some
questions
all right thank you senator ron johnson
wisconsin we're going to be watching
your election
re-election hopefully hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else